ATM ATM an automated teller machine
correct
oh okay we'll take five suggestions and
we'll drop the beat we'll uh do a rap
about it so
um let's kind of start on this side of
the room what would you guys like a wrap
there's a hand up there yes what would
you like that
exhausting exhausted the word exhausted
I like it thank you very much unless
that was just a very passive aggressive
heckle
great exhausted and there's a hand up
here from the table of the person with
crutches right and so before we do that
may ask how you came about your your
crutch incident
it was a first date you have to ask
before you get the kiss you have to get
away
so what you're on a first date
you went ice skating you are you thought
you were so smooth
you saved a couple of children
so you are well on your way to getting
at least a [__] on this day
[Applause]
you sacrificed yourself
I mean yeah you expanding on this is not
going to be any more impressive than
what we're all thinking in our head
well done
um okay so you're on your table you had
a suggestion what was it
your birthday Jaylen Jalen
like Jalen hurts yeah that means a lot
to me
uh I'm going to assume that's a sports
person right
Jalen hurts is a football player
a quarterback okay an American football
player well yes I figured that if it was
a British football player I would have
[__] known wouldn't I
also no one in Britain is called Jalen
hurts that's not a name in our country
you call Jeremiah ouchy calm down
so Jalen has a supporter back for your
team for the Eagles so he he
um the other guy he was he the MVP you
said no he wasn't no the other guy was
okay so Jalen hurts what what's Jalen
hurts known for outside of football
being a beast
outside of football as well
absolutely okay great he's just a
gentleman okay
were you on a date with Jalen hurts is
that
it actually went really well Chris I
need these crutches because of how hard
he [__] me
MVP for most violent penis
okay Jalen hurts so the only thing I
know from the super was that it was the
first people to have two black
quarterbacks right or like first time in
a long time yeah yeah okay first time
ever okay cool great well that's that's
it he's a beast he was in the Super Bowl
and he squats 500 pounds yeah
okay Jalen hurts fan club is here and
this is like the split from Rome in the
Catholic Church like you're like 500
pounds 610 actually Chris no we pray for
the Pope in Rome no we pray to the Pope
in Avignon
okay Jalen hurts great exhausted middle
of the room
um yeah yes the lady or person I
literally said lady because you're
wearing white and then I realized men
can wear white as well what was it ATM
ATM an automated teller machine correct
oh okay
you can I'm in silly baby get it right
all right wow I'm glad I knew that now
because after the show I was gonna go
and get some cash out I'd go up to the
nearest homeless guy because they know
where the cash machines are excuse me do
you know where I can find ATM
if you give me 20 right here
so ass to mouth that's the the sexual
exploit from anal intercourse directly
to the oral cavity with no no grooming
or no cleansing in between
[Applause]
[Music]
it's not true
ATM exhausted Jalen hurts okay now this
this is oh sorry I just tried on your
foot I do apologize
um however if it's on the stage then I
am liable to tread on it uh this this
side over here who's got a suggestion
yeah
feeding Gizmo after dark that's a that's
a Gremlins reference for those who don't
know
um you're not allowed to get him where
you know to feed him after dark and then
this side of the room you get the final
suggestion yes oh my friend in the
Argentina shirt would you like a rapper
a while how about are you from Street
Fighter versus Leo
[__] losers spot the losers in the
room
[Applause]
it's surprising to see so many of you
sat next to women tonight you've got
girlfriends well this is a wrap based on
exhausted Jalen hurts ATM and uh feeling
Gizmo after midnight and Rio versus Neo
Let's uh let's do this this is all made
up get excited
two stones don't know what it is bro
watching Gremlins late night Corky's
more my favorite fluffy guy getting from
old Chinatown the guy with the beard
mustache drooping down is like careful
you've gotta do it right don't get him
down you never feed him after midnight
like the opposite a Cinderella goes to a
pumpkin you feed him something redness
stuff jumped in emerging from deep in
his paws they're green horrible things
green called up with the claws they
start coming after you invading the town
you like Gizmo his fur white and brown
that's the half a color of the hadouken
Street Fighter yes they do Newcomb but
this one a real beat em up if you've
never watched this Chun-Li keeps it up
the tick on me she's attractive for an
animated girl where are you going to the
Matrix the world in 1999 controlled by
the squid robots and agent Smith is like
yo lots of people underground who's this
Morpheus says Leo use this spoon there
is no spoon but who comes through
hadouken hadouken yes that's Ryu he
bursts in and of course Neo said news
Hand Luke Skywalker with the force
because you're nerds I knew that you'd
like that later he starts fighting the
green lightsaber and so his Street
Fighter Neo and the guy with the sword
it's like a little triangle one of
them's cord through the middle and Neo
he Dodges he mines bend it backwards
with the bullet time I can't do it
properly but here we go again I'm
exhausted man rap into the children of
the 80s playing games on their snares or
on their Sega Mega Drive what is this oh
I'm so knackered I'm really cream
crackered take a little break pause
while this rapper talks about exhaustion
baby have a nap but not right now cause
we do the freestyle rap coming over here
you know what makes the [__] squirt a
six ten squatting guy call Jalen hurt
the ladies will love him the guys do too
but there's a disagreement between you
two 500
but can't win the ring still he's the
MVP of entering anybody you're nowhere
about starting at the back door then he
says ass to mouth and of course
if he asks you say yes I want to do that
oral and anal Ingress why do I motion on
this just flip them around yeah spin it
a bit from the bum to the Yum the bum to
the Yum the bum yum bum yum yum it's fun
yeah you've gotta be careful don't get
it wrong why use a BJ just use a tongue
start scraping off it offends you don't
worry it's a clean bum had an enema made
sure it's scraped out that's what it do
and what's this Leo but [__] Ryu
there we go the ATM when he's shooting
and when Ryan comes he shouts Hadouken
hahaha
[Applause]
[Music]